wir bleiben beim thema urlaub wechseln
aber aufs wasser sie haben inzwischen
mitbekommen die kreuzfahrtsaison hat bei
tui schon wieder begonnen mit
griechenland touren dort wo man auch
tatsächlich bedenkenlos urlaub machen
kann nur da gab es dann plötzlich
meldungen dass zwölf mitglieder der crew
corona infiziert werden
mein kollege kai franzke der ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet der den fall auch
betreut war auch selbst auf mein schiff
sechs wie siehst du die lage von denen
sechs oder von den crooner infizierten
gibt es jetzt keinen mehr der tod
spricht da von einem fehlalarm was es da
genau passiert
naja also ist wäre eine katastrophe
gewesen wenn diese 12 infizierten
crewmitglieder tatsächlich auch beim
zweiten test positiv gewesen wäre
sind sie aber nicht es war ein böser
labor fehler aus meiner sicht was davon
nie mehr passieren das wäre ein
millionenschaden für tui gewesen und
deshalb sind jetzt tui und auch ganz
viele reiseveranstalter und sehr froh
dass ich das aufgeklärt hat und jetzt
erstmal weiter wären wenn es wäre eine
absolute katastrophe gewesen
du warst selbst auf mein schiff sechs
jetzt vor diesen vorfällen auf was muss
man sich da einstellen wie es jetzt
kreuzfahrt unter krone aspekten
es ist anders also wenn man vielleicht
vor 23 jahren die erste kreuzfahrt
gemacht hätte wir haben direkt
wahrscheinlich weil es war alles so
locker landausflügen entweder einen sich
einen posten gebucht oder eben man ist
auf eigene faust dadurch sein ziel
gerannt und hat das alles selber für
sich entdeckt jetzt ist eben alles
anders also man muss am tisch sitzen
beim restaurant dann dafür ist die maske
ausziehen selbst an deck muss man wenn
man um das schiff herum läuft auch eine
maske tragen die ausflüge muss man also
ein ausflug auf die akropolis zum
beispiel kostet inzwischen 60 euro pro
person
das handy muss fragt zu erfüllen ist
dabei die busfahrt zurück und eben auch
die führung aber man muss sie gut man
muss in der truppe bleiben wenn man
nicht in der gruppe bleibt hat man das
problem weil dann darf noch nicht nur
schiff und ihr weißes beendet auf eigene
kosten
ja und das ist ja auch passiert
tatsächlich jetzt haben wir uns ein
bisschen sorgen gemacht um dieses schiff
wir haben gesehen dass tatsächlich das
schiff jetzt einen tag länger im hafen
von piräus liegt quasi wie was wirst du
verdaut wie ist da die stimmung also die
stimmung ja ja also ist alles sparen
natürlich aber werde auf diesem schiff
aktuell ist wer sich aktuell trauten
freut zwar zu machen
der ist natürlich fehlen und sagt es ist
alles ganz toll
der kapitän informiert uns wir wissen
was auf uns zukommt aber naja also die
reise hätte jetzt wenn nur ein positiver
test dabei gewesen wäre die reise vorbei
gewesen und 1300 euro
die muss man erst mal aufbringen und
tatsächlich die zuschauer oder die gäste
sind dort sehr erleichtert gewesen wir
schauen mal rein in ein video von
instagram da gibt es wirklich applaus
für die kuh tatsächlich unglaubliche
erleichterung an deck von mein schiff 6
und tatsächlich ist es auch zu verstehen
klar jeder redet über das schiff und am
ende gibt's halt überhaupt keine corona
infizierten wir wollen dann noch mal
nachhaken wir sind auch verbunden mit
gott ja sonnigsten die pressesprecherin
von tui cruises hallo
sind sie dann auch so erleichtert wenn
die leute an bord sind sie auch so
erleichtert wie die gäste an bord
ach wissen sie es sind tatsächlich gute
nachrichten aber nicht nur sind das gute
nachrichten
weil wir keine fälle an bord haben
sondern es sind auch gute nachrichten
weil wir merken dass unsere prozesse
funktionieren
es ist ja so dass wir nicht erst seit
kurzem fan sondern seit ende juli
tatsächlich schon mit gästen unterwegs
sind
mit einem strengen hygiene konzept das
ist richtig aber auch mit sehr sehr
vielen positiven rückmeldungen
und wir sind auf alle fälle vorbereitet
von daher würde ich tatsächlich nicht
von einer katastrophe sprechen wir
selbst wenn wir positive fälle an bord
gehabt hätten
wir wissen genau wie wir damit umzugehen
haben und haben das auch im vorfeld mit
den behörden abgesprochen und abgestimmt
sowohl mit den deutschen behörden als
auch mit den griechischen behörden und
daher hatten wir also zu keinem moment
irgendwie panik oder sorge sondern waren
da sind das ganze ganz ruhig angegangen
mein kollege franz k hat gerade gesagt
gäbe es dort ein bestätigten corona fall
an bord hätte die kreuzfahrt
unterbrochen oder abgesagt werden müssen
wie sehen sie das
das ist so nicht korrekt ist es so dass
wir ganz genau regeln haben wie wir mit
einem positiven fall umgehen würden
und zwar ist es so dass wenn jemand
positiv auf corona getestet würde dann
würden wir den gast isolieren und im
nächsten hafen würden wir dem gast eine
rückreise oder sammer würden wir den dem
gast den behörden und übergeben und dann
je nach dem ob symptome gibt oder nicht
natürlich versorgen
von daher ist es nicht so dass bei einem
positiven zahlen oder zwei positiven
fällen
das gleicht einen kreuzfahrt abbruch
bedeutet das ist nicht so tatsächlich
muss man festhalten es war ein totaler
hardcore tui cruises fans an bord
tatsächlich das waren treueste kunden
die sich endlich gefreut haben dass
kreuzfahrten wieder losgehen tatsächlich
die frage rechnet sich das sind ja mit
deutlich weniger passagieren losgefahren
auf der anderen seite welches signal
geben diese meldung über die angeblich
corona infizierten jetzt leuten die
sagen möchte ich mal ausprobieren ich
möchte gern mal meine erste kreuzfahrt
machen ist das nicht doch ein image
haben ja ich glaube wie gesagt und ich
will das gar nicht beschädigen natürlich
freuen wir uns wenn es keine feld an
bord gibt dass das ist natürlich klar
und wir haben uns gefreut dass es keine
positiven fälle gibt aber wie gesagt
dass wir mit solchen verdachtsfällen als
wir sind professionell umgehen auch
gemeinsam mit den behörden ist glaube
ich auch ein zeichen dass kreuzfahrten
auch zu corona zeiten möglich sind und
das nicht nur für die fans sondern auch
für diejenigen die vielleicht kreuzfahrt
essen wollen ich nehme mal an kämpfen es
dazu tatsächlich natürlich muss man
danach fragen
nehmen wir mal auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff gäbe es tatsächlich
corona infizierte wäre das ein
reisemangel und wie sollte ich mich das
reisen da verhalten also wenn es zu
beeinträchtigungen kommt auf der fahrt
warum auch immer
dann kann das durchaus einen mangel sein
er würde dann eben dazu führen dass ein
teil des reisepreises preis
erstattungsfähig wäre wenn es jetzt zur
beeinträchtigung käme
obwohl bei den neubuchungen müssen wir
uns natürlich überlegen wir wissen ja im
grunde genommen worauf wir uns einlassen
das ist eben möglicherweise
beeinträchtigungen geben kann
beispielsweise das tragen von masken
oder bestimmte bereiche die eben nicht
zugänglich sind das ist ja jetzt bei den
neubuchungen ist das bekannt so dass das
dann kein mangel mehr wäre ein mann ist
es nur wenn man bei vertrags eingehung
eben nicht damit rechnen musste und das
bezieht sich ja nur auf die alten
verträge die also vor der korona zeit
geschlossen wurden und jetzt eben
ausgeführt werden die neuverträge sind
eben nicht mehr so ich sag mal mangel
behaftet durch diese beeinträchtigung
weil das von vornherein klar ist das
heißt man muss schon auch ein bisschen
damit rechnen dass es zu
beeinträchtigungen kommen kann in
welcher form auch immer
und irgendwas auch ins kalkül ziehen
jedenfalls die gäste an bord sind total
begeistert ihm nochmals franzke dazu du
warst an bord hat auch mit vielen gästen
gesprochen und wir sehen diese bilder
über soziale netzwerke kaiser etwas dazu
und das ist dieses gefühl was ich im
maintal kreuzfahrturlauber sind doch
kreuzfahrt fans die kämpfen natürlich
jetzt auch damit sie wieder tui mein
schiff damit sie die nächste tour machen
können das ist eine tolle gemeinschaft
die das board ist und das merkt man eben
jetzt auch gerade noch mal alle fans und
natürlich von diesem tollen kapitän sind
der immer die ruhe bewahrt hat das war
schon vor zwei wochen so nur eben etwas
pensionisten eben sagte das ist eben die
theorien dass man wenn ein positiver
fall an bord ist
diese maßnahmen einleitet die praxis
haben wir jetzt gott sei dank nicht
kennengelernt weil ich stelle es mir
dann tatsächlich schwierig vor weil
diese person bis der test oder das
testergebnis ja da ist schon mit anderen
kontakt hatte und darin dann mit seiner
begleitperson sehr wahrscheinlich
demnach hätten wir eventuell schon
zweifel
dennoch finde ich auch habe ich das
sogar genommen vor 14 tagen die po
versucht alles um diese massnahmen
einzuhalten und also das konzept ist
schon richtig gut und ausgereift
allein bis man an bord ist was man daran
dass gesundheit zeigen dass diese
negativen corona test alles vorliegen
muss da kann man sich schon sehr sicher
man ja